I understand that I'm putting you on the
spot because these developments are
fluid but we have been reporting on the
events in Turkey I'd like to get your
thoughts well thank you we know very
little about what's happening in Turkey
you've seen these competing claims the
turkish prime minister says that the
government's in control but now this
email to journalists from the turkish
military saying that it is in control
it's not entirely surprising the
relationship between the turkish
military and the government of president
air duan has been very tense and
distrustful for many years there are
elements in the turkish military that
see themselves in essence as the
guardians of a secular isn't islam the
islam developed by camel Ataturk back in
the the government secular government
developed by Ataturk in the 20s and 30s
president air do one of course has
brought Islam into the center of Turkish
political life and into the Turkish
Constitution that could be a possible
explanation but there are many others
more recently president era Diwan has of
course relaxed turkey's relationship
with Russia and with Israel and there
may be some unhappiness about that this
is pure speculation at this point until
we know more about the situation on the
ground mr. ambassador the US could find
itself squarely into this we have an
airbase in Turkey we have a very
important airbase that we use the
interlocked air base in Turkey very very
important base actually for our
operations against the Islamic state
Turkey of course is one of our most
important NATO allies it has one of the
largest and most capable militaries in
the entire NATO alliance and
geopolitically there isn't a more
important country than Turkey if you see
it situated very close to contiguous to
the Middle East as well as the Russian
Federation so what happens there is of
major importance to the United States
sir what happens if this in fact unfolds
the way it appears to be right now where
there is a military uprising where the
military is attempting to take control
of the government what will that mean
for stability in the region what will it
mean for the United States and I'm sorry
it's just impossible to answer the
question because we don't know who these
military officers are we don't know what
they stand for we don't know what their
intentions are we don't know whether
they
want to reestablish a secular Islamic
regime in Turkey we don't know whether
there is unhappiness over the over
what's happening in the Syria and Syria
war and the war against the Islamic
state of course another big issue in
Turkey itself is the role of the Kurds
and the long struggle of the Turkish
government and military I've had against
the PKK weren't the mainline Kurdish
separatist group and so it is just pure
speculation at this point as to what
would happen but if you're looking for
countries that are vital to the national
security interests of the United States
turkeys if it is is among those
countries at the top of the list
worldwide given all the things that we
do with the Turks day in and day out in
the fight against the Islamic state
obviously but also within the larger the
larger view of what we do in NATO